hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight the HBO series containing
the fewest games and least impressive
throngs we are off this week for
Memorial Day but we wanted to briefly
check in to run a new segment by you
because on our show we often ask the
question how is this still a thing which
we inquire in an effort to understand
why we're still subjected to things like
daylight savings time and the Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Edition but tonight
in the interest of innovation we'd like
to do the exact opposite of that and
pose the question how is this not a
thing because while there are many
things in this world that should no
longer be things there are also many non
things that should absolutely be thin
off' I'd brought into the things istant
if you will you know like an old dog
version of the Blue Man Group around
exactly what how is how is that not a
thing or a universal safe word for
getting out of small talk that's run its
course strawberries strawberries please
strawberries so I cannot hear about your
kayak a weekend strawberries
strawberries brilliant strawberries now
but we don't have either of those things
nor do we have a way to wink without
looking like you're proposing a
threesome or ambien but for getting
through the part of the day when you're
awake and and I wanted to know why not
just as I want to know when is science
going to get around to inventing a
biodegradable treadmill that starts to
break down after a month of misuse and
disuse it's environmentally friendly and
it saves you the humiliation of selling
barely used exercised equipment on
Craigslist but we have failed to pursue
those dreams just as we failed to create
a house key that cries like a baby if
you're about to leave home without it
and perhaps most frustratingly of all
why do we not yet have bread pants which
are of course sweatpants but made of
bread in my experience if you're wearing
sweatpants you're probably concurrently
eating something messy like a big plate
of nachos or a fistful of hummus now
with bread pants if you spill you don't
wash the pants you simply tear a piece
off the leg and you eat that too how are
those not a thing
how are those not a thing curl up red
pants not a thief help and finally
finally how is there not a search engine
built just for parents that lets them
search terms like the guy who's on that
show we like and oh she's married to
what's-his-face because the answers to
both of those questions are always Mark
Harmon and Blake Lively that is all for
now we'll be back on June 5th when we
will return to be covering things that
already exist thank you very much good